[Music]
on this Wednesday night the Russian
president's plan to ramp up his war in
Ukraine Vladimir Putin's latest threaten
you believe this is not a bluff the
response from Ukraine and the West
public inquests ordered into the
Saskatchewan stabbing Rampage when
families of victims could get some
answers travel mandates departing what's
waiting in the wings for arrive can and
vaccine requirements and meet the coupon
Nanny we saved 200.71 cents The
Connoisseur coaching Canadians on how to
cut Rising food costs
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcha
good evening and thanks for joining us
there has been a dangerous escalation in
the war on Ukraine Russian President
Vladimir Putin has ordered 300 000
reservists to be mobilized to fight in
his first TV address since the invasion
began Putin also strongly implied he's
prepared to use nuclear weapons
those who tried to Blackmail us with
nuclear weapons should know that the
prevailing winds can also blow in their
Direction
Putin's address comes as world leaders
speak at the United Nations in New York
appearing via recorded video this is
some of what Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski had to say
Ukraine wants peace Europe one space the
world wants peace and we have sin who is
the only one who wants War
it is a risky political move for Putin
but one that sends a clear message to
both the Russian people and the West U.S
President Biden says the world must be
clear firm and unwavering in its resolve
against Russian aggression in Ukraine in
our top story tonight Redmond Shannon
takes a look at what this major move
could mean for the war
Russians protesting against the
mobilization of 300 000 reservists for
the war in Ukraine the recruits would
add to the almost 200 000 troops
initially deployed to The Invasion
comes just hours after President
Vladimir Putin's u-turn on his earlier
pledge not to mobilize this his first
national TV address of this type since
the February invasion
Putin also said he will support this
month's so-called referendums on joining
Russia taking place in four Ukrainian
regions
Russian installed authorities will hold
the votes in the two self-declared
donbass republics Donetsk and luhansk
and in the curse on and zaparisia
regions although Russia does not hold
full control over any of them the
referendums are being widely condemned
internationally as shams
Russia does annex new land the Kremlin
would crucially regard it as Russian
soil if the territorial Integrity of our
country is threatened we will without
question use all the means at our
disposal to protect Russia and our
people this is not a bluff all means
would of course include nuclear weapons
he's lying like always he is bluffing
Ukrainian MP Alexi goncharenko believes
Putin's plan is a sign of desperation
he's urging the West not to Blink in its
support of Ukraine the more Ukraine will
receive Weaponry today
the quicker everything will finish but
some Ukrainian analysts fear the nuclear
threat should be taken seriously given
that Russia is on the back foot and
Ukraine is unwilling to compromise on
its borders
which in specifically stated that uh
that he does not deliver there is any
possibility or peaceful deal and the
same was stated by zelensky many
multiple times whatever happens next the
growing Specter of a nuclear threat is
undoubtedly an inflection point in this
brutal conflict Redmond Shannon Global
News London
Abigail Beeman is in New York watching
what the U.N general assembly is doing
as the situation between Russia and
Ukraine intensifies Abigail condemnation
is one thing but will the U.N take
further action
Ukraine tops the agenda as world leaders
meet here both the U.S and Ukrainian
presidents address the general assembly
Wednesday and while many including
Canada condemn Russia's actions how far
the West is prepared to go is unclear
Russia has shamelessly violated the
court tenants of the United Nations
Charter U.S President Joe Biden condemns
Russia's invasion in clear terms a
brutal needless War
a war chosen by one man calling for
support from member states the timing of
Putin's escalated nuclear threat during
the un's general assembly is not lost on
anyone a nuclear war cannot be won
and must never be fought
we are facing an unprecedented situation
where one of the founding members of the
United Nations a member of the permanent
Security Council
is violating the most basic tenets of
what the UN stands for Canada is focused
on Ukraine here too we
need a meeting with the president of
Moldova which borders Ukraine and is
threatened by Russia one of several on
the prime minister's agenda he is first
of all uh
having to move towards at least a
partial conscription in Russia which is
a step closer to admitting what he has
not wanted to admit to Russians that
this is a war that he has launched
unjustifiably against a neighbor
is an example of things not going toward
to his plan while Canada sends Aid and
continues to insist We Stand by Ukraine
how far that help will go as the war
drags on and the aid calls increase is
not clear neither for our country nor
allies punishment for torches and
humiliations of women and men punishment
for their catastrophic turbulence that
Russia provoked with its illegal War we
could be at a turning point they are
winning and now really is the time to
double down on our support for them
Biden also spoke out against Security
Council Members using veto Powers as
Russia has done the U.S is calling for
an expansion to Security Council seats
Canada hasn't had a spot in more than 20
years and lost in its last two bids nitu
Abigail Beeman in New York thanks
Abigail
Saskatchewan's Chief coroner has
announced there will be a public inquest
into the horrific Mass stabbings that
took place earlier this month in James
Smith Cree Nation and the nearby
community of Weldon but the families of
the ten victims will have to wait a year
before they learn more about what
happened and why
with the suspect deceased there will be
there will not be a public criminal
trial
without a public hearing of the facts it
will leave many questions unanswered
from the families involved and the
public
pertaining to the circumstances leading
to the deaths
the death of suspect Damian Sanderson
will be considered as part of the public
inquest a separate inquest will be held
to examine the in-custody death of the
other suspect miles Sanderson both
inquests will take place next year after
the police investigation is finished and
as Heather your ex West explains they
will be heard by juries comprised
entirely of indigenous people
for the past two and a half weeks the
people of the James Smith Cree Nation
have been doing their best to grieve and
heal we're having daily sweats Elders
medicine men that are here
traditional Healers
uh therapists their Collective trauma
one of the largest mass killings in
Canadian history most of the Dead
Mothers Brothers a Canadian veteran have
now been laid to rest but so many
questions around the horrific events
remain today
I am announcing that an inquest will be
held for the 11 deaths that occurred on
the James Smith Cree Nation and in
Weldon on September 4 2022.
a separate inquest will be held for the
death of Miles Sanderson standard
practice for anyone who dies while in
police custody
Sanderson was arrested several days
after the killings following a prairie
wide Manhunt his cause of death has
still not been made public though the
coroner revealed Tuesday it was not
caused by blunt force trauma I would
like to remind the families and the
public that an inquest is not designed
to find fault the chief coroner says the
inquest will serve the same purpose as
Nova scotia's mass casualty inquiry a
jury will hear facts and make
recommendations though in this case each
member of the six-person jury will be
indigenous and the inquests will be held
as close to the James Smith Cree Nation
as possible Mark arkhand lost his sister
and her son he says news of the inquests
brought mixed emotions maybe some of my
family have to testify and kind of
relive this but at the same time
it'll uh probably give us some answers
as to what happened at the best that
they can nothing will bring back the
ones who have been lost but answers
could help those grieving move on
Heather your expressed Global News
Calgary
there is a lot of Buzz today about
changes coming to Canada's covid-19
border mandates Global News has learned
the federal government is preparing to
drop vaccine requirements for arriving
Travelers and the controversial arrive
can app is set to become optional the
government is expected to make these
changes by the end of the month but
Ottawa is still clearly not ready to
divulge its plans
how can I say something that hasn't
happened yet like you're asking me to
make an announcement about a decision
that has not been taken so it's not
secrecy
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is joining us now so Mercedes
what do we know about these changes
well nithu we know they're expected to
kick in on September 30th although none
of them are final yet and that's because
cabinet hasn't met that's happening
tomorrow and that's when prime minister
Justin Trudeau is expected to sign off
on the following changes number one that
vaccination requirement for arriving
Travelers is going to go away and with
it the arrive can app will go away in
terms of being mandatory it'll still be
optional but you won't have to fill it
out to get across the border what is
staying though is masking policies so
you will still have to wear your mask
while you are flying or on a train in
Canada this has been a huge issue the
vaccinations and the arrive can app from
a political liability perspective for
this government there's not a lot of
political issues that really Reach Out
And Touch people and affect them
directly but these were two it was
affecting people in Border towns and
tourism areas who are reliant on
tourists coming here some of whom
weren't vaccinated or couldn't figure
out the up there was more than ten
thousand people accidentally wrongly
quarantined as a result of the glitch in
the app so with the snowbird season just
ahead nithu this was potentially
becoming an even bigger issue for the
government and they wanted to get rid of
it as one of the last countries actually
to do so
and Mercedes as we wait to hear what the
finalized plan will be what can
Canadians expect next
so the Mets big debate might be masking
policy and we heard about this from
WestJet today WestJet put out a
statement saying that mask
non-compliance and enforcement on our
aircraft continues to be a source of
disruption for our people and guests and
this transition is critical to align
with other major Nations so they want
the government to drop that masking
policy but there's no sign of that on
the horizon at this point ethu we expect
the other changes to become signed off
on tomorrow by prime minister Justin
Trudeau Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
Mercedes thanks so much
another legal hurdle for Donald Trump
coming up who's suing the former U.S
president and why plus the intensifying
fury of hurricane Fiona
Fiona has now strengthened to a category
4 hurricane the huge storm already
pounded parts of the Caribbean killing
at least five people and wiping out
critical infrastructure an estimated 80
percent of Puerto Rico is without power
and running water
Fiona is bearing down on Bermuda before
it slams the Atlantic coast Environment
Canada says the storm is expected to
transition to a post-tropical storm
Friday night as it approaches Nova
Scotia and residents are being warned to
prepare for high winds and up to 200
millimeters of rain
former U.S president Donald Trump is now
facing another legal storm New York's
attorney general is suing Trump his
children and Senior Executives of the
Trump Organization for fraud the civil
suit alleges they purposely inflated the
value of assets to secure more favorable
loans Reggie cicchini reports
his name is synonymous with wealth and
power but Donald Trump now risks losing
both no one is above the law after a
hard-fought battle to obtain information
New York's attorney general Leticia
James filed a civil lawsuit against
Trump three of his children and key
Executives from the family company
accusing them of falsely inflating
assets by billions of dollars claiming
you have money that you do not have
does not amount to the art of the deal
it's the art of the steel the suit seeks
250 million dollars in penalties and
could prevent the trumps from conducting
business in New York we show that they
violated several state criminal laws
millions of pages of documents were
reviewed and dozens of witnesses gave
interviews including Donald Trump who
invoked his Fifth Amendment right more
than 400 times everything was done with
the knowledge and at the direction of Mr
trump it was that 2019 testimony from
Michael Cohen a former Ally that
kick-started this investigation after he
exposed how Trump operated his company
he is a con man
and he is a cheat Trump's team chalks
this up to a political Witch Hunt the
Attorney General a Democrat is up for
re-election in November and this kind of
announcement does break with Norms the
informal tradition is you don't do that
sort of thing during the height of an
election season now while this is a
civil action James also made criminal
referrals to the southern district of
New York and the IRS which could result
in new federal investigations Just As
Trump is expected to announce a new
presidential campaign
Reggie chakini Global News Washington
protests and reaction to the death of an
Iranian woman in custody are growing
inside the country and around the world
women in the capital Tehran are burning
their head scarves in an act of defiance
against the country's dress code
internationally protests and
condemnation against the actions of
morality police were seen in Istanbul
Berlin Beirut the U.S and Canada with
the United Nations calling for an
impartial investigation into Masa
amini's death
I had police in Ontario honor a fallen
officer after he was gunned down in
senseless violence
thousands gathered in Toronto today for
the funeral of constable Andrew Hong he
was one of three victims who died in a
shooting spree that involved police from
across Southern Ontario Mike drolets on
the emotional service and tributes that
float in from his families at work and
at home
as a sea of blue swept across the city
Sarah Crook and her son Sammy like so
many others stood silently on the street
to pay their respects to the memory of
constable Andrew Hong it's a heavy day
it's a really heavy day
over 7 000 officers took part in the
standing room only service a
heartbreaking and personal Affair for so
many including Hong's daughter Mia who
said they joked how he was the king of
useless information yet she soaked up
all he had to give Dad thank you for
everything you've taught me I won't
forget it I promise Hong was one of
three people murdered in a shooting
rampage last week that investigators now
say began with a targeted attack on a
random police officer Hong however they
still don't know the motive of the
shooter Sean Petrie a 40 year old with
an extensive criminal history who later
died in a shootout
from the service that police continue to
wrestle with what happened and that
hunger as he was known at work was as
loved on the job as he was at home he
was devoted to his career but he lived
for his family tomorrow
would be our 21st wedding anniversary
so Andrew
if you are listening
please know
that you will always and forever be the
greatest love of my life
happy anniversary
microwave Global News Toronto
coupon nanny who is helping more
Canadians cut down the pressures of
inflation
after a few weeks of lower late summer
prices the cost to gas up your vehicle
is starting to climb back up as usual
drivers in British Columbia are feeling
it first with the price of a liter of
regular climbing by as much as 14 cents
overnight to just over two dollars
though the price jump won't be quite as
extreme the shift is expected to repeat
across the country and to be mirrored in
the U.S over the coming days
inflation is making it harder than ever
for Canadians to pay their bills so it's
no surprise more families are trying to
cut costs by cutting out coupons now a
Nova Scotia woman who's persevered
through her own hardship has emerged as
a leader in this new trend Ross Lorde
reports on the coupon Nanny and her
growing following
for Canadians these days day-to-day
living is less about what they earn than
how much they save
these are great coupons as you can see
they're for a wide variety of products
two of these Dana Calder knows all about
saving since she started couponing for
herself and her children Calder has
perfected the art of cutting down on
grocery bills we only spent 51 dollars
we saved 200.71 cents so literally we
say four times what we spent this
grandmother of five has adopted a
nickname the coupon Nanny with punishing
inflation making some food products
three times more expensive her free
advice to others on how to save has
never been more timely her online
following has doubled recently reaching
a wider audience by the day they're
starting to realize that by using
coupons and cash back options that's
bringing prices down 10 20 30 40 dollars
per grocery trip cutting corners on
everything from bacon to baby formula I
started couponing when he was a 14 month
that's when I started using a baby
formula
and it's like fairly expensive at that
time and I was like searching around
looking for ways to get the formula for
cheer and that's where I found her page
on Facebook then it knows all about
tight finances she's on a Disability
Pension for post-traumatic stress
disorder from her time as a correctional
officer at any time any of us could be
in that situation excuse me I probably
don't get emotional there are more ways
than ever to use coupons from the
traditional method of cutting them out
of flyers or collecting from grocery
store aisles to printing or mailing them
out from online apps Shoppers can also
scan their grocery receipts to a cash
back app and get a credit in their debit
account on my web page you can go to one
place and put coupon networks and it'll
list all the different places you can
find coupons online and it will say
beside it if they're printable if
they're mailable if you can just load
them onto your phone Dana says she
doesn't play favorites if you don't
discriminate it's fair game it's I have
no association with any of the stores
anything like that my job is to help
people find the cheapest yeah prices
yeah including sharing her know-how in
person to clients transitioning out of a
nearby homeless shelter she's a wealth
of knowledge and everybody that
participated was really excited by the
apps and the tips and and all of the
stuff that she presented to them if
everybody would just help each other a
little bit every we'd be able to get
through this Dana's generosity is coming
full circle a graphic designer giving
her website a free makeover so she can
start selling ads to recover some costs
for a service she's currently providing
at her own expense Ross lore Global News
North River Nova Scotia
and that is global national for this
Wednesday night I'm Nito Garcia
tonight's your Canada is Chance Cove
Newfoundland and Labrador we love seeing
your Canada please email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching and we hope to see you again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]